[Music]
turning to politics now we are just over
three weeks away from election day and
early voting is
right around the corner here in nevada
both parties ramping up their local
efforts
orca manon joins us live now from las
vegas city hall one of our
local mail ballot drop-off sites with
more on the efforts orco
well sasha clark county has started to
send these mail-in ballots to all
registered voters in the county
and you can either mail them in or drop
them off at various sites around town
including here at las vegas city hall
the candidates knowing now is the time
to make their pitch to nevada voters
last week heavy hitters from both
campaigns made their way to the las
vegas valley on thursday
vice president mike pence rallied
supporters in boulder city
then on friday democratic presidential
nominee joe biden
held a couple different events in town
he spoke to latino leaders and hosted a
driving event
and in a one-on-one interview with me
biden continued to blast trump's
coronavirus
response pence also attacking the
democrats
the way the administration has handled
the covenant situation has been
irresponsible
totally irresponsible and gave
no national guidelines basically said
the governors are on your own
and didn't provide you want to abolish
fossil fuel fuels
use taxpayer funds to abortion
they want to defund the police and if
you couldn't figure it out last night
they want to pack the supreme court
a brand new cbs news battleground poll
shows biden leading trump by six points
here in nevada
but the gop is moving full steam ahead
the president's daughter ivanka trump
will be in las vegas tomorrow
to share her father's make america great
again agenda with local supporters
again mail-in ballots are currently
being sent out to voters here
in clark county early voting runs from
october 17th to the 30th
and there will be more than 100
in-person polling locations
on election day which is tuesday
november 3rd reporting live from
downtown las vegas tonight orco mana 8
news now